elles sont ancrées dans les villages du
parc naturel elle s'entoure de jardin de
balcons de ferronnerie travailler et
affiche d'élégantes silhouette
ce sont les résidences de villégiature
donc la villégiature c'est une pratique
qui est très ancienne en fait il remonte
aux romains les roamad les villas
romaines par exemple à pompéi ou même à
rome donc les romains riches comme pline
l'ancien par exemple opine le jeune
avait des villages des villes à ce
qu'ils appelaient les villas c'est à
dire des maisons de villégiature dans
lesquelles ils allaient pour un séjour
relativement long ce qui distingue la on
parle bien de villégiature et pas de
tourisme
la villégiature c'est donc un séjour à
la campagne dans une propriété pour y
trouver le repos le bonheur et pratiquer
des loisirs intellectuelle lecture
musique ou autres avec le plus souvent
un jardin pour y cultiver ses produits
au 19e siècle la villégiature devient
également un mode de vie c'est pas la
vie en ville ou
on a des soirées chics là on vit
simplement on reçoit ses amis ont fait
des jeux on joue aux cartes on joue au
billard la salle de billard est un des
attributs de la villégiature
et puis on profite de la vue aussi parce
que très souvent ces maisons de
villégiature
elles sont situées en haut d'une colline
ou au bord d'une rivière enfin en haut
d'une rivière sur les coteaux d'une
rivière pour recenser ces villes là le
parc réalise des inventaires en
collaboration avec le service patrimoine
et inventaires de la région ile de
france
il identifie les différentes communes et
bâtiment a répertorié ensuite les
équipes partent sur le terrain pour
faire des observations et des relevés
plus précis
ces maisons ont beaucoup de points
communs architecturaux et malgré tout il
existe beaucoup de variété de formes et
de matériaux
or elles sont ici c'est vraiment
particulier parce que la meulière est
partout elles sont en meulière mais
assorti de briques assorti de céramique
de couleur c'est relativement sobre
quand ma vie à des maisons de
villégiature à la même époque en bord de
mer par exemple il ya des maisons de
villégiature balnéaire qui sont beaucoup
plus pittoresques avec beaucoup plus de
décor avec des des fermes apparente à
jour et du bois ici c'est une
architecture relativement sobre une fois
les inventaires terminée ils seront
ensuite publiées sur le site du parc est
accessible à tous chacun pourra ainsi en
savoir un peu plus sur l'histoire de sa
maison et ainsi mieux respecter
l'histoire du bâti